[Music]
[Applause]
there are many guys in the history of
college athletics who won a national
championship for
a baseball team and a football team in
the same year but anthony munoz did pro
football hall of fame offensive lineman
11 time pro bowler what kind of baseball
player were you
anthony
in my mind or in others
but you played third base
well i played third base through high
school actually i started playing dan
third base it's great being with you
good seeing you good seeing you um so i
started playing third base at the age of
seven and that was my childhood dream so
through little league
three years starter in high school
mainly third base but also pitched of
course i went to usc on a football
scholarship with the agreement to play
baseball and so i didn't play my
freshman year there but my sophomore
year in school was my freshman year
playing baseball played a little first
base d8 but then i was mainly a relief
pitcher once my arm got into shape
i was a fungal hitter no longer playing
first or batting but i did pitch a
little bit uh i was a relief pitcher at
usc did you ever face uh randy johnson
i didn't in fact randy i think got there
like four years after i got there um
i left my the year i played was 78
graduated in 80. so
bengals i was a rookie in age so i think
randy johnson was there a couple years
two three four years after i got uh
after i left it's probably a good thing
you didn't face him
yeah i'm i'm glad i didn't face
something you know being i guess what
was he six ten about 100 miles an hour
and i faced some good heat in college
but i don't think i faced anything like
his i i was wondering about the
evolution of the offensive lineman
because we talk about the evolution of
wide receivers and quarterbacks other
positions
but
it i'm curious of how you played this
style and then running the uh
linemen that are coming into the nfl now
what's the biggest difference with when
you played as opposed to what they want
a lineman to be now
i think their bank balance you know what
they have in their checking and their
savings probably the biggest difference
[Laughter]
no you know it's it's amazing because
they there's no question about it dan
they're bigger they're stronger they're
quicker
you know it's one of those things where
you just look at them and you know they
are getting bigger uh in certain areas
but you know when you look at it it
still boils down to being able to do the
basics you know run blocking pass block
being able to move your feet use your
hands and just because you're big and
strong and fast doesn't necessarily
translate
into being in the right position using
the right kick using the right step
using the right place hand you know the
right hand placement so it's still you
still got to be taught you still got to
go you know and frank pollock who's the
bengals line coach i i think he has a
great tagline he says
mastering the mundane
and i think as an offensive lineman you
have to have the mentality and the will
to do that because you have to really do
it over and over and over and to me
that's the difference between a good and
a great offensive line and lyman is
being able to master the technique and
use it consist consistently how would
you deal with aaron donald
well i would uh there would be a word in
my vocabulary hey guard help help help
no
you know those those are the top type of
guys that uh you would want to be
challenged and watching him
it boils down to technique i mean
just because like i said you're big and
strong and quick and fast with him
you can throw that out the window it's
going to help you dan but you have to be
not that anyone's perfect but you have
to be near the perfect every time you
set with your your hands not leaning not
allowing him to use your weight to
counter and throw it just it's a matter
of really focusing and using the correct
technique and i had one of the best
technical coaches ever in jim mcnally
and we worked over and over so that's
how
i would deal with it if i had to go
against someone like aaron donald what's
it like if you've given up a sack and
you have to go back to the quarterback
either to help him up or you go into the
huddle do you say anything
you don't i think looks say everything
you have to be able to wipe it clean and
one of the things i use an example for
those have watched men in black the
movie they have that little gadget that
you click and it
your memory is gone
as an offensive tackle you have to you
have to do that i mean you know you see
their boomer laying on the ground or
kenny anderson you help them up and you
just say to yourself that cannot happen
again and hopefully it doesn't happen
the rest of that game and hopefully for
you know for me i didn't want it to
happen the rest of the season
you were in the coldest game ever
it was a little chilly but that was the
san diego game
and i was there
i was working
i think if you could have said to dan
feltz and the chargers hey you guys
don't have to play you can go back on
the bus get on the plane and go back
home you're going to lose let's say
we're going to say you lost by three
points you played well but you don't
have to play in the game i honestly
thought when they walked onto the field
i thought there was no way that they
were going to win that game just with
their body language how much did you got
because you guys had
didn't you have sleeveless shirts on or
you didn't have undershirts on nothing
like that
well we felt we were crazy to play in
that game might as well come out with no
sleeves
that was the decision we made as an
offensive line so here's actually 59
below this is what i had on a great
t-shirt
shoulder pads and my jersey
uh we knew we had them dan we came out
to pre-game warm-up and all the
offensive lineman sleeveless we looked
over to the charger sideline
there was two guys
pregame warm-up that had no sleeves
we went in came out for the kick out and
we made it a point
to browse the sideline and find those
two guys and see how how many layers
they put in when they went inside and
they had at least two or three layers
when they came out i said
okay and it's interesting because people
asked me after the fact
did you do that to have a psychological
edge now come on i'm a football player
offensive lineman
we're not thinking psychology but when
it was all said and done
i think that happened and uh you know
not to mention that kenny anderson
without gloves mind you
played and threw the football
unbelievably
i i want to get him into the hall of
fame
i think amen
you know kenny anderson
you know
just sort of forgotten you know
you guys didn't beat montana in the
super bowl that would have gone a long
way i think in getting him in the hall
of fame
uh you know kenny riley like there's
been a couple of players
with with the uh the bengals but i
wonder how that
hurt kenny anderson that he didn't beat
montana that head-to-head super bowl in
detroit
you know you hate to think that that's
the difference because all you have to
do is look at his career stats
and and i've been looking at him a lot
because i'm one of the biggest advocate
it's gotten to a point where it's really
really frustrating for me because you
know we're a super bowl in minnesota
several years ago we're sitting there
and it's kenny anderson roger staubach
and myself and we're in a conversation
all of a sudden
staubach stops and he goes by the way
why the heck aren't you in the hall of
fame talking to kenny anderson a lot of
guys that believe that and uh but you
know
i think there's a lot of people that
justify quarterbacks careers by the
rings they have and i'm just not one of
those guys
to me one of my top five quarterbacks
doesn't have a ring and that's the kid
that played down in miami dan marino
so hopefully this year we have kenny
riley and kenny anderson as finalists in
the seniors category
i tell you what i'm one of the biggest
advocates for both those guys especially
kenny anderson but now you look at kenny
riley the top eight
all-time interceptors seven of them
some of them are in the hall of fame the
number five guy is not in and that's
number 13 the rattler kenny riley so
you know it's getting frustrating and
hopefully this year
we get one maybe two and uh soon maybe
both
talking to anthony munoz pro football
hall of famer when you see montana
do you ever talk about the super bowls
after i body slam them no we don't
you know we don't and and that's the
great thing about it i think you have
other guys that talk more about it than
the guys you actually lost to
um you know so you know we we have great
you know great talks i don't see him a
whole lot but when we see him it's
friendly conversation we're at events
and it's time just to enjoy but uh we
really don't talk about uh you know
because i don't want to get back into
counseling after losing fight
how do you uh how do you sum up what
you've seen from joe burrow
i tell you what i love the guy i mean
i've had a chance to talk to him not a
lot
look forward to getting to know him even
better but what i see as a leader
and i mean for a second-year guy to be
concerned i mean the guy's an amazing
leader great talent but i just love the
way i love watching how guys interact
now
uh and the way people interact with them
what they're saying about them you know
it's real and uh to me he's the real
deal he's the total package and i just
love watching them play because for
years
they would get behind and you would say
oh maybe they can come from behind now
it's like as long as he has the football
in his hands we have a chance and and
not only him but they've surrounded him
with some amazing talent defensively
offensively
so i feel good about the direction this
team's going with joe burrow at the helm
uh i mentioned you went to usc
so much for the pac-12 there anthony
with usc going to big 10 you're you're
living in ohio so they're they're coming
to big ten country
you know mixed feelings with that for me
i'm excited because now i don't have to
go out west all the time to watch a game
and over the years i've been a guy
that's supported and i go to at least
one or two games a year
but what 2024 i think is when they start
maybe you know maybe two games a year
they'll be out here uh you know it
happened so quickly dan i i can't say
that i was surprised
because in college all you have to look
at and it's uh you know it's about the
money nil you know kids are the portal
they're going to where they can get
money and now teams are going to
conferences where you know they can get
the most money so
i think it's competition wise i mean i
thought the the pac-12 was down a little
bit we had some pretty good teams but
now you know i think it's going to be
competition and hopefully it helps the
recruiting for us
where's your gold jacket
right now it's hanging up in my closet i
just took it out of my carry bag after
getting home yesterday from canton ohio
and it's hanging up in my
my closet uh i actually
didn't have to worry as much as i
usually did just a couple events so with
the heat you usually have to take it in
and get it dry clean because i perspire
or i should say i sweat a lot
but i just hung it up and kind of made
sure it went too wrinkled in my closet
put your hands up to the screen how
are they are they messed up oh my god oh
my god
nine out of 10.
i mean you got you got
i mean that that's pointing to like
indiana isn't it
well yeah i don't like giving directions
unless
i misdirect people with that you know
hey just go straight ahead wait
you're pointing over
how did you get that injury
you know i was at an auction once and
the bid was up to 300 i said 300
300 not
you know dan
over the years we were i was a big you
know
from my usc days we were hands arms i
mean extended punch them and you know
all those years of punching those
defensive ends as they're coming full
speed i'm thankful that there's only one
going in the wrong direction but you
know people ask me they know that i
played a lot of years in the nfl and
they said so how'd that happen
how did you do that i said well you know
i was out back gardening and i got it
caught in the root of a plant
no it's just those big guys man you get
a cot between jerseys helmets shoulder
pads and i'm just thankful like i said
there's one of the ten that's going in
the wrong but could you get that
repaired if you wanted to
i could but it would remain straight i
wouldn't be able to bring it in when i
make a fist i can still make a fist i
can still grab things i can still grab
the club and wait so yeah why mess with
it it makes you know we would have never
talked about it if it was great right it
makes for a great conversation piece
it's great to talk to you i tell the
story
when we were at espn and i used to joke
with anthony i'd say man if i played
against you i would do this and he had
no idea that i was going to do like a
swim move around him
and then i did i did one where he goes
do that again
and then i did it and you grabbed me in
the ribs
and you held me for like 10 seconds and
then you said don't do that again
and i couldn't breathe i went okay
all right
you for reminding me
it's fun just like when you asked me
about how good a baseball player was you
know it's like you know i enjoyed it but
to face a nolan ryan you know randy
johnson or steve carl no i think i'll
pass on that yes i i learned my lesson
like man i could get by you
then all of a sudden he's like do that
again i did
but you never held anybody when you
played right now
never i just did that i just did that to
you to just kind of i never really held
anything thank you anthony great to talk
to you as always
all right dan good being with the great
seeing you that's anthony munoz pro
football hall of famer he went to the
pro bowl 11 times
and a member of the 1978 usc national
champs